MATT WALSH COME APPRECIATE YOU
COMING ON TONIGHT.
>> APPRECIATED, THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: THERE'S A LOT OF
FAKENESS IN THIS COUNTRY BUT IS
THERE A CORPORATION IN AMERICA
BAKER THAN PATAGONIA?
A MARKETING COMPANY THAT POSES
AS A MOUNTAINEERING EXPEDITION
IN ORDER TO SELL SHODDILY MADE
PLASTIC CLOTHING DID NONPROFIT
EXECUTIVES WHO RARELY GO
OUTSIDE.
PATAGONIA'S PROMOTIONAL
MATERIALS DESCRIBED AS TOTAL
DEDICATION TO FIGHTING CLIMATE
CHANGE BUT SOMEHOW THEY FORGET
TO MENTION ITS ENTIRE PRODUCT
LINE IS MADE FROM FOSSIL FUELS.
PATAGONIA IS THE KIND OF PLACE
THAT WILL GIVE YOU A LECTURE
ABOUT FAIR TRADE AND CORPORATE
RESPONSIBILITY EVEN AS IT
OUTSOURCES ITS OWN MANUFACTURING
TO SWEATSHOPS AND THE WORLD'S
MOST IMPOVERISHED COUNTRIES.
ENJOY YOUR $300 CASUAL WEAR
HOODIE, SOME KID IN SRI LANKA
GOT $0.20 TO MAKE IT.
PATAGONIA MAY BE THE SINGLE MOST
AUDACIOUS SCAM AND ALL OF
AMERICAN BUSINESS AND THAT IS
SAYING SOMETHING.
SO PROBABLY SHOULDN'T SURPRISE
YOU THAT PATAGONIA HAS DECIDED
IT SHOULD CONTROL AMERICAN
POLITICS.
A GROUP OF AMERICAN THEY FLEW TO
JACKSON WYOMING FOR A PRIVATE
FUND-RAISER.
THIS WAS NOT UNUSUAL, RAISING
MONEY AND RESORTS DOWN AND
UNFORTUNATELY, THE GROUP FORGOT
TO ASK PATAGONIA FIRST.
WHEN PATAGONIA EXECUTIVES
DISCOVERED THAT REPUBLICANS HAD
TRAVELED TO WYOMING WITHOUT
THEIR PERMISSION, THEY THREW A
FIT.
THEY ANNOUNCED A BOYCOTT OF THE
SKI RESORT.
THEIR REASONING?
THEIR COMPANY THEY EXPLAINED
SUPPORTS "A STRONG DEMOCRACY."
OF COURSE.
A STRONG DEMOCRACY.
DEMOCRACY IS A SYSTEM WHERE A
SMALL GROUP OF SMOG INHERITED
MONEY BILLIONAIRES DECIDES WHO
IS ALLOWED TO SPEAK IN PUBLIC
AND WHO HAD BETTER SHUT UP OR
FACE PUNISHMENT.
WE USED TO CALL THAT SYSTEM
OLIGARCHY BUT THE TERM HAD
UNPLEASANT AUTHORITARIAN RING.
SO THE GENIUS AS A PATAGONIA
RENAMED IT AND IT IS NOW CALLED
DEMOCRACY.
THAT'S A LITTLE LIKE TAKING SPUN
POLYESTER FIBER MADE FROM OIL
AND CALLING IT SHEARLING WALL
WHICH COMES FROM SHEEP AND
HOPING NO ON